hai visto merlino
[Musica]
hai visto merlino mi ha morso
per fortuna non mi ha fatto niente
grazie per questi paesini
ma che cosa farà mi è venuta un'idea
forse merlino essendo un cane riuscirà a
capire il lupo proviamo a far avvicinare
berlino al lupo e vediamo se riesce a
capire che cosa vuole ma molto attento
ok
devi solo dirmi che cosa vuole il lupo
se riesci a capirlo
[Musica]
che cosa vuole il gruppo marlino temi
berlino sta guardando la vuole qualcosa
là fuori
marino sta andando verso la finestra
vuole dirmi qualcosa
berlino che cosa che ha detto il lupo
devo chiudere le tende parlino devo
chiudere le tende
ho capito merlino vuole che io chiuda le
tende probabilmente al lupo da fastidio
alla luce del sole
ma che cosa sta facendo vitale in
giardino adesso vitale e ancora nella
mafia che dorme non si è accorto di
niente
prova a chiudere le tende vediamo se il
lupo ci dirà qualcosa
ecco fatto e un po più inquietante
adesso al buio
berlino che faccio adesso
berlino
[Musica]
che cosa vuole mi sa dire che cosa vuole
il lupo adesso prova a tradurre che cosa
vuole penso che il lupo voglia entrare
ora che ho chiuso le tende e ho fatto
più buio berlino allontanati dai giganti
berlino lasciano lacerando arrivano non
mi arrivò marino allontanati fini fu
anderlino
mario tafaro un lupo che cos'è berlino
l'ottavo abbracciarlo perfino sembra che
piace a proprio questo lupo quindi forse
vuol dire che non vuole farci del male
marino quindi non vuole farci del male
altrimenti berlino avrebbe paura eh sì
proprio un lupo strano perché sei così
grande e così alto perché stai su due
zampe non su quattro zampe no aspetta un
momento un occhio azzurro è un occhio
marone che cosa strana ho un dubbio tu
non sei un lungo vero quindi se un lupo
mannaro sei un cane un umano
forse ho capito sei un uomo lupo
hai capito berlino significa che metà
uomo metà al lupo posso farti delle
domande
ok
innanzitutto volevo dirti che non voglio
farti del male ok spero che anche tu non
è che potresti dirmi perché sei qua a ho
capito vuoi dirmi che non puoi parlare
non riesci a parlare ok allora ti farò
delle domande in cui vuoi rispondere
solo sì o no quindi se sei un uomo lupo
riesci a capire quello che dice berlino
riesce a comunicare con berlino potresti
dire a berlino una cosa da parte mia di
a berlino che gli voglio tanto bene
hai visto berlino
che fa merlino
berlino il sole caldo affezionato al
lupo force sta seguendo il gruppo sembra
che gli piace proprio
berlino posso fidarmi di questo cane
lupo allora che cosa vuol dire quello
che cosa voleva dire a dire che posso
fidarmi di te
meno male quindi ti da fastidio alla
luce del sole
sembra che sia un sì questo per me sei
qua perché sei venuto qua anno è vero
poi rispondere solo sì o no stai
cercando qualcosa un oggetto
[Musica]
stai cercando un oggetto che cosa può
essere è quell oggetto e in questa casa
[Musica]
e in questa stanza per un oggetto
pericoloso un oggetto pericoloso che
cosa ho una domanda importantissima da
farti rispondi sinceramente ok tu sei
venuto qua per farci del male
meno male ok allora non c'è problema che
aiuterò a trovare questo oggetto così
potrei tornare da dove sei venuto cosa
può essere da questa parte ok ti aiuto
io a cercare è un pupazzo no non è un
pupazzo questa scatolina col punto di
domanda
sembra che si sia arrabbiato so cosa può
essere utile un uomo lupo tra fatali un
pupazzetto e tieni un pupazzo già non
fare come merlino che vuole mangiare i
pupazzi ok lascia lo lascia lo lascio il
calcio è visto berlino fa come teme
mangiare i pupazzi vuol dire che siete
molto carini a sieve berlino che cosa
sta cercando il lupo firma youtube
indicami che cosa sta cercando il lupo
[Musica]
che cosa vuol dire estratto la non
merino allontanati la scatola
che non deve essere aperta questa che
stai cercando
devi sapere una cosa questa scatola è
molto pericoloso ogni tanto escono fuori
volte che insomma è una lunga storia
comunque è molto pericolosa non posso
darti questa scatola anzi non deve
proprio essere aperta lina spostati
dagli stati spostati merlino non fargli
credere che ci si può avvicinare a
questa scatola altrimenti lui vorrà
prenderla e sarà molto pericoloso per
tutti noi
il telefono sta squillando caro uomo
lupo no niente questo è solo un telefono
che ho dimenticato dentro alla scatola
penso che devo per forza rispondere
altrimenti non smetterà di scrittore se
è così mi fai paura cui rispondere tu al
telefono io gay lo prendo subito calmati
eccolo qua che c'è berlino dove dire che
non devo rispondere ma il nostro è
sempre meglio non rispondere a questo
telefono ma devo per forza rispondere
rispondiamo nuovamente al telefono vi
ricordate cosa succede ogni volta che
rispondo al telefono lasciato come piace
per portarmi fortuna pronto
no non mi sto divertendo che cosa vuoi
hai mandato tu il lupo uomo lupo perché
che cosa vuoi da noi perché i mandato da
noi l'uomo lupo prima devi dirmi che
cosa vuoi da noi
dimmi come far tornare a casa l'uomo
lupo
no non te lo posso lasciaci in pace ok
vitale che cosa sta succedendo a vitale
[Musica]
e va bene te lo passo ma lasciaci in
pace poi ok ora parlare con te
deve per forza parlare con te altrimenti
ha detto che farà del male a vitale che
cosa le sarà di 100 che immobile
[Musica]
dato che succeda marino cosa cosa forse
è meglio toglierli il carrello
che succede
sembra che da quando abbiamo parlato di
telefono sia diventato aggressivo o no
che cosa faccio
[Musica]